(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] We came together
to accomplish a mission.
We will be walking around
six to eight hours.
We want to show the world
that with the proper prosthetic care,
and orthotic care, it
makes a big difference
in someone's life.
(gentle music)
(clicking)
(rustling)
My name's Kionte Storey.
I lost my leg back in 2010
overseas in Afghanistan.
I'm with the United States Marines.
After my injury, I felt lost and confused.
A lot of questions of
why, why am I still alive?
Why am I here?
Suicidal thoughts, which
made waking up everyday
very difficult.
(cheering)
Being active for me
just became my therapy.
I found myself inspiring others,
and motivating others
to be active as well.
(gentle music)
Currently we're in Ecuador climbing
for Range of Motion Project,
which is a local organization
providing prosthetic
and orthotic care to countries
who don't have the means
to provide such care
to their citizens.
We have 10 to 12 amputees
climbing Cayambe Volcano.
We all come from different backgrounds
and all different injuries.
To be a part of such a team,
to me is very, very important,
and it's very inspiring.
(gentle music)
Summiting Cayambe from the refuge
will take about 12 hours.
We have the equipment and the gear,
but we have to be patient and
wait for the right weather
to get to the summit safely.
Whether we summit Cayambe Volcano or not,
it is just a small part
of what we're here to do.
With this climb, I hope
others will learn a lot
about themselves and their abilities.
They can do anything they want to.
There is nothing that is impossible.